Os voy a hacer una pregunta ¿Conocéis a
esta mujer?
Se llama Ursula Von der Leyen.
Y os puedo asegurar que hace un mes no tenía
ni idea de quién era esta señora.
Y como yo el 90% de los europeos.
Pues bien, esta mujer alemana está a punto
de convertirse en la Presidenta de la Comisión
Europea.
La persona más poderosa de la Unión Europea.
Para que os hagáis una idea, a partir del
1 de noviembre, que es cuando tiene previsto
jurar el cargo, Von der Leyen será la homóloga
europea a Donald Trump.
Y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos.
Sobretodo los que hayáis votado en las elecciones
europeas… ¿Pero esta mujer… de dónde
ha salido?
Como sabéis, en mayo de este año, 2019,
los europeos fuimos a las urnas.
Os lo explicamos aquí, en VisualPolitik,
en un vídeo que hicimos con Kurzgesadt que
merece la pena ver aunque sólo sea por las
animaciones tan bonitas que tiene.
Pues bien, millones de ciudadanos europeos
metimos un papelito en las urnas para elegir
a nuestros representantes en el Parlamento
Europeo.
Y no, el nombre de Úrsula Von der Leyen no
estaba en ninguna de las papeletas.
Nadie la nombró en ningún debate.
Y, por supuesto, no dio ninguna entrevista.
Por aquellos tiempos, esta mujer sólo era
la ministra de defensa de Alemania.
Los alemanes la conocerían mucho pero para
el resto de los europeos, era completamente
irrelevante.
Y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos:
en las elecciones europeas no se vota al presidente
de la comisión.
Y tenéis razón.
En las elecciones votamos al parlamento, es
decir, al legislativo.
Después, el legislativo es quien elije al
presidente del ejecutivo.
Todo eso es cierto.
Es decir, que aunque Von der Leyen no se presentara
a las elecciones, es perfectamente legal que
la nombren presidenta.
Ahora bien… políticamente es un movimiento
difícil de entender.
Por poner un ejemplo, sería como si el parlamento
español, en lugar de elegir uno de los candidatos
a las elecciones, terminara eligiendo al consejero
de salud de Andalucía.
Legalmente sería posible pero… políticamente
sería un escándalo.
Y sí, es cierto, el nombramiento de Von Der
Leyen es un hecho histórico.
Será la primera mujer que gobierne Europa.
Tal vez en un futuro, recordaremos su nombre
junto al de Margaret Thatcher o Angela Merkel.
Probablemente sea una gran presidenta.
Pero la pregunta que hoy nos hacemos es ¿Hasta
qué punto puede decirse que la Unión Europea
es democrática si Ursula Von der Leyen ha
sido elegida sin presentarse a las elecciones?
¿Cuál es el papel del presidente de la Comisión
Europea?
Es más, ¿Qué se puede esperar de la Comisión
Von der Leyen?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
LA BURBUJA BRUSELITA
En el año 1992 se firmó el acuerdo de Maastrich.
Podríamos decir que ese fue el momento en
el que nació la Unión Europea, con capital
en Bruselas, Bélgica.
Hasta ese momento, la Comunidad Económica
Europea era solamente eso: una comunidad económica.
Un macro acuerdo de libre comercio pero que
apenas tenía implicaciones políticas.
Pues bien, en 1992 nació la Unión Europea,
que es un gobierno que engloba a todos los
países miembros.
Después aparecería el EURO, el tratado de
Amsterdam, el tratado de Niza y el de Lisboa.
Todos ellos documentos muy complicados que
nunca se han terminado de explicar muy bien.
A día de hoy, prácticamente nadie entiende
cómo funciona la Unión Europea.
Y los medios de comunicación no ayudan.
Habréis oído mil veces repetir “Bruselas
dice esto”, “Bruselas pide nosequé…”
pero lo cierto es que Bruselas, es decir,
Europa, tiene 3 instituciones muy importantes.
Y cada actúa de formas distintas.
Vamos a explicarlo con un ejemplo que conocéis
todos: el dichoso ARTÍCULO 13.
Para quien no lo sepa, cuando digo Artículo
13 me refiero a la directiva europea que regula
el copyright para los youtubers, que hemos
hablado hasta la saciedad de ello.
Pero en este caso, no vamos a centrarnos en
lo que dice la ley sino en cual es todo el
proceso legislativo para sacarla.
Pues bien, todo empieza con el CONSEJO EUROPEO.
Aquí es donde están representados todos
los países miembros y dicen “necesitamos
una ley para regular el copyright en Internet”.
Escriben unas líneas generales en un documento
y se lo mandan a la COMISIÓN EUROPEA.
La COMISIÓN EUROPEA sería lo más parecido
al brazo ejecutivo en Europa.
Tiene un presidente, y unos comisarios, que
serían el equivalente a los ministros o los
secretarios de Estado de Estados Unidos.
En la comisión europea se leen ese documento
con las líneas maestras y sacan una propuesta
legislativa.
Es decir, un borrador de ley.
Y después, cuando han terminado de escribirlo,
se lo mandan al Parlamento Europeo.
El parlamento Europeo, que también lo podemos
llamar Eurocámara, funciona como cualquier
otro parlamento del mundo pero tiene una característica
única.
No tienen la iniciativa legislativa, es decir,
no pueden proponer una ley.
Sólo pueden discutir lo que les llega de
la Comisión Europea.
Así que los diputados discuten, crean sus
grupos de estudio y finalmente sacan una versión
nueva de la ley.
Pero, si recordáis el vídeo que hicimos
sobre el Artículo 13… el diablo está en
los detalles.
Es decir, que siempre hay más detalles que
tenemos que pulir.
Y aquí es cuando llegamos a la fase de los
triálogos.
Los triálogos son un proceso en el que se
juntan representantes del Parlemento, la Comisión
y el Consejo.
Y ahí es donde discuten los últimos detalles
de la ley.
Y al final, después de meses de negociación,
sale una ley definitiva que se vuelve a votar
en el Parlamento.
Pero, en este caso, no se pueden discutir
detalles: los diputados sólo pueden votar
SÍ o NO.
Fijaos bien en una cosa: según este sistema,
la Comisión Europea tiene muchísimo poder.
Son los únicos que pueden proponer legislación
en el parlamento.
Por ejemplo, en un país como España, el
Gobierno suele proponer leyes pero también
el propio parlamento puede sacar sus propias
propuestas.
En
este caso, todo el poder lo tiene la comisión.
Y este detalle es muy importante.
El consejo europeo está compuesto por gobiernos
elegidos por los votantes de cada país.
Es decir, que se ha elegido democráticamente.
El parlamento se elige en las elecciones,
así que es totalmente democrático.
Pero ¿Y quién elige al presidente o la presidenta
de la comisión?
Y aquí es donde llegamos al gran debate.
Hace 5 años, algunos políticos propusieron
el sistema de SPITZENKANDIDATEN.
Básicamente, cada partido político elige
a su candidato para presidente.
Es decir, que aunque tu votes a una lista
de eurodiputados, también sabes a quien vas
a votar.
En cierto modo, sería un sistema parecido
al de España, por ejemplo.
En España no votamos al presidente del gobierno.
Pero todos sabemos que, cuando votamos a una
lista de diputados del Partido Socialista,
estos intentarán hacer que Pedro Sánchez
sea presidente.
¿El problema?
Que muchos partidos políticos y muchos países
miembros no estaban de acuerdo.
Pensadlo bien, como decíamos antes, ahora
mismo el CONSEJO EUROPEO, compuesto por los
gobiernos de todos los países miembros, puede
elegir a quien quiera como presidente.
Sin embargo, con este sistema, sólo podrían
elegir dentro de una lista muy pequeña propuesta
por los partidos.
Así es que, durante unos años, esto del
SPITZENKANDIDATEN se convirtió en un simple
acuerdo de caballeros.
Y eso es exactamente lo que ocurrió en las
elecciones de 2014.
En este caso, los dos partidos más votados,
los socialdemócratas y los populares, formaron
un gobierno de coalición.
El SPITZENKANDIDATEN del Partido Popular era
Jean Claude Juncker.
Así que, como eran la primera fuerza, Juncker
pasó a ser el presidente de la comisión,
apoyado por populares y socialdemócratas.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Qué ha pasado en estas
elecciones de 2019?
Pues lo que pasa muchas veces con los pactos
de caballeros y las normas no escritas…
que siempre llega alguien que no quiere cumplirlas.
En este caso, los populares y los socialdemócratas
no suman mayoría absoluta.
Necesitan el apoyo de los liberales.
Y los liberales no quieren a ninguno de los
SPITZENKANDIDATEN que habían propuesto los
grandes partidos.
Y la pregunta es… ¿Por qué han terminado
eligiendo a la Ministra de Defensa de Alemania?
La respuesta es una lucha de poder.
Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
SPITZENKANDIDATEN?
NON MERCI
Hay 5 top Jobs en la Unión Europea.
Son los 5 cargos que más poder tienen en
toda Europa.
Y esos cargos son el Presidente de la Comisión,
el Vicepresidente, que se encarga de política
exterior, el presidente del Parlamento Europeo,
el del Consejo Europeo y, finalmente, el del
Banco Central Europeo.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Quién elige a estos
5 top Jobs?
Según el Tratado de Lisboa, lo tiene que
hacer el CONSEJO EUROPEO.
Es decir, el órgano donde están los presidentes
de todos los países miembros.
Después, necesitan que el Parlamento Europeo
lo apruebe.
En principio, parecería razonable que el
presidente fuera el Spitzenkandidaten del
partido más votado ¿Quién estaba a favor
de este sistema?
Por supuesto, los dos grandes partidos ¿Quién
estaba en contra?
Pues… os lo podéis imaginar.
El partido de Macron rechaza el proceso de
Spitzenkandidaten
Pensadlo bien.
El partido de Macron, los liberales, es la
tercera fuerza más votada en Europa.
Es decir, que no son muy fuertes.
Pero Macron, como presidente de Francia, tiene
muchísimo poder en el Consejo.
Además, dentro del Consejo, Francia y Alemania
suelen ir de la mano.
Y no olvidéis que son los dos países más
grandes de la unión.
Así que, básicamente, Macron dijo “no
quiero ningún spitzenkandidaten” y Merkel
le dijo “vale, ponemos a quien tu quieras
pero, eh!
Que se alemán”.
Y así es como salió el nombre de Ursula
Von der Leyen.
Alemana pero nacida y criada en Bélgica.
Habla 5 idiomas y por lo que dicen los mentideros
de Bruselas, debe tener amigos hasta en el
infierno.
Básicamente, la clásica persona que te encuentras
en una fiesta y que cae bien a todo el mundo.
Vamos, que el resto de países miembros en
seguida se hicieron amigo suyo.
Y muchos diréis ¡Venga ya, Fonseca!
No me creo que una decisión tan importante
se tome así.
Pues, mis queridos amigos de VisualPolitik…
la política es así.
Veréis, cuando hacemos análisis políticos,
muchas veces intentamos centrarnos en datos
económicos, estrategias electorales, encuestas…
pero no olvidéis que, quienes toman las decisiones
son gente de carne y hueso como yo y todos
vosotros.
Y muchas veces, algo tan tonto como contar
un chiste a tiempo en una fiesta puede ser
crucial para caer bien a quien tienes que
caerle bien.
En Europa, este tipo de maniobras tienen un
nombre: la burbuja Bruselita.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque la jugada
de Macrón va más allá!
Después de nombrar a la presidenta de la
comisión, Macrón ha dicho “oye, Merkel,
ahora que ya has puesto a una alemana de tu
cuerda por aquí… ¿Me dejas poner a una
francesa en el Banco Central Europeo?
Y para eso ¿Quién tiene un mejor curriculum
que Cristine Lagarde, que ha sido presidenta
del FMI?
En este caso, Macron a matado a dos pájaros
de un tiro.
Por un lado, coloca a una francesa y por el
otro, se quita de en medio a una posible rival
en las elecciones.
Christine Lagarde, la presidenta soñada de
los franceses
Pero esperad un momento, porque recordad que
Ursula Von der Leyen debía lograr el visto
bueno de la Eurocámara.
Y aunque haya sido por 9 votos, lo ha conseguido.
Atentos.
LA COMISIÓN VON DER LEYEN
Según varias encuestas, el principal motivo
por el que los británicos votaron el BREXIT
era la falta de control ciudadano sobre los
asuntos europeos.
Y claro, después de todo lo que hemos contado,
me reconoceréis que algo de razón no les
falta.
Sobretodo cuando leemos titulares como este.
Atentos a las declaraciones del que fue el
SPITZENKANDIDATEN de los populares, MANFRED
WEBER.
Weber insta a los europarlamentarios a rechazar
las decisiones tomadas en la trastienda de
la diplomacia
Y ahora, atentos a los que ha dicho justo
un mes después.
El alemán Weber insta a los europarlamentarios
a respaldar a Von der Leyen en la votación
para su top job
Muy probablemente, este cambio de opinión
sea simplemente el resultado de una negociación
de despacho.
Es decir, nada de democracia y mucho de conversaciones
privadas.
De nuevo, la burbuja bruselita.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Qué va a pasar ahora?
¿Qué esperamos que haga la señora Von der
Leyen cuando llegue a su despacho?
Pues lo primero que tiene que hacer es nombrar
a los comisarios, que, como os decía antes,
son el equivalente a los ministros.
Tienen que ser 28, uno por cada país miembro.
Es decir, no puede haber dos alemanes, por
ejemplo.
Ahora bien, no es lo mismo ser el comisario
de hacienda y finanzas, por ejemplo, que el
de ayuda humanitaria.
De momento ha anunciado que tendrá un Colegio
con paridad de comisarios entre hombres y
mujeres.
Cada país tiene un comisario.
A Von der Leyen corresponde asignarles las
funciones que considere oportunas.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque no es tan
sencillo!
Después de que Von der Leyen nombre a los
comisarios, tiene que ir al Parlamento Europeo.
Los exámenes del Parlamento Europeo a los
Comisarios no son un trámite.
En estas audiencias suelen caer un par de
candidatos.
Por ejemplo, en 2014, la candidata eslovena
no paso los exámenes y hubo que buscar a
otra.
Es decir, que Von der Leyen puede tener algún
que otro dolor de cabeza a la hora de formar
gobierno.
Pero ahora la pregunta es para vosotros, ¿Creéis
que ha hecho bien Macron en liquidar el sistema
Spitzenkandidaten?
¿Tienen razón los euroescépticos cuando
hablan de falta de democracia en Europa?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Y como siempre, no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semana,s así que suscribíos
a este canal, que es completamente gratuito,
y os permitirá estar al tanto de todas nuestras
actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
¡Un abrazo y hasta pronto!